bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
io sono fa vincere questo tolto il siamo
sul tonno che non riesca a dirlo tonti
noc twice ce l'ho fatto che sarebbe non
bussare di morte nuovo gioco 126 stupido
che devo dire buongiorno
già troppe cose che stanno succedendo
aiuto c'è un fuoco c'è una musica bella
c'è un quadro ancora più bello e mi sono
al telefono e si chiudono le porte e
tuona e poi cos'altro parte cose in un
gioco solo buongiorno premi primo seno
sia del siena o se facebook li lasciami
in pace casa ma perché è tradotto in
italiano
però così nel family friendly prendi il
candelabro per illuminare la strada
perché cesta facebook 4 voglio bello
sfugga alle labbra che non eccolo questo
è fatto da dio la grafica è fatta la di
rega incredibile dollari poco immagino
ok se si bussa solo una volta regale
usate la candela per accendere un attimo
per accendere le candele sul muro avanti
prega tutti calmi perché qua sta
diventando una cosa molto triste o
madonna perché è staccato l'elettricità
ti odio
stavo sul divano io queste share chi ti
caga ed emana che sbatte la porta e
chiude orlando
e poi polmone
vabbè allegra la giornata meno male si
testimoni di geova ragazzi non capisco
chi è che bussa nei giochi poi a prince
e mai nessuno non ho mai capito sta roba
rega che fastidio allora io esco
perfetto per questo momento che non si
apre più ma guardava ci avrei scommesso
quello che voleva c'è qualcuno che sta
posare salve
devo guardare il telefono
sì non avrai mica intenzione di
lasciarmi nuovo stronza egoista ma io
sono una femmina quindi di stare calma
perché non dico niente tu mi insulti
lavoro iniziato il video maledetta
hayter schifosa però non è quello e non
è che ti devo lasciare che non si
chiudono le porte non si aprono più
tranne questo questi aperto che si e
aperto pregustano porta o ecco sono
tornato in casa chiuri chiusi per l'amor
di dio dvd mamma mia casa arrivo chloe
però visto che non c'è niente di
paranormale non vedo perché un quadro
debba staccarsi da solo però lo è
6 biso capisce anche lei mi si è spenta
proprio candelabro lo è
arona ruzgar
non posso far st vita rega ve lo dico e
di sopra permesso lo è lo è
dopo quanto classista casa madonna ma
enorme
cioè non l'ho mai amato i corridoi che
sono i campi da calcio ma che è però e
sei qua ecco allora qua prima no lo è
qualcuno che mi spiega che cosa sta
succedendo per favore se questo lo
sgabuzzino no vabbè ma non si possono
chiudere tutte le porte nei giochi che
non muori
[Musica]
non lo so che cosa sta succedendo non lo
so se c'è qualcun altro ma sicuramente
le porte non si chiudono da sole e i
quadri consistenti madonna che è bello
vedere che c'è compagnia forecast she's
mine
lei è mia ma no anche no cosa c'era
dentro muro entrata nel muro tipo il
binario 9 trequarti bene io uscirei rega
sta diventando veramente la cosa triste
io ve lo dico non vorrei farmi ma chi è
che sano di mente si comprerebbe una
casa così fatemi capire qual è il
problema
gli spieghi tu dove sei andata sta
evocando satana nel tempo libero con
rosmarino
non lo so questo momento mi servirebbe
che tu mi desse una mano perché non c'è
un microonde bro per evocare satana
serve a microonde bene la pizza con una
pizza chievo col signore della pizza
fammi una diavola fatta bene porca vacca
thomas a e thomas l'acqua dal pozzo per
purificare la livelli innocenti che
divora bene a nel retro c'è scritto
questo hai bisogno di l'acqua del pozzo
vogliamo l'acqua dal pozzo il bicchiere
cavazza la tazzina prevo cassata nata
tanino satanasso ciao già il dottor
campus girarlo ok posso prendere il
calice di gesù come no 6 svecchiato
tutto lo sapevo e quindi a poco se arma
non c'è bisogno che porti tu le cose da
satana esaltano anche le porte a sé
quindi bene è aperto
perché mi stai facendo questo vorrei
fossi ma ora sto facendo niente
ma cosa vuoi la vita mia per fare questo
le donne si è chiusa la parte non si
apre più guardate qualche coincidenza
non avrei mai detto toto lacca per
capelli tua madre non me l'aspettavo mai
che poi mi è cascata per terra proprio
qui devo guardare lì per per prenderlo
bene la racca immagino io possa fare
delle robe tipo questo bene queste
benzina io vi do fuoco
io non so dove stiamo andando ma più
lontano vado a ballare da chloe e meglio
è ok sono tornati qua alla fine tutto
sto casino sempre un antico va bene
gioco dell'anno comunque gioco in cui
l'arma da difesa e una lacca per capelli
come immagino che ci sia lo è
chloe c'è
ci sono le magie la tua stanza
wingardium leviosa e funziona quanto
vedo comunque ricordati che leviosa non
leviosa centrare bene che mi fanno
entrare poi in casa tranquilli in una
sede posto sono spaventato a morte è
venuta per me è tutta colpa mia
nel mentre che vola mandai messaggi che
brava chloe possono fare qua il tablet
per evocare satana sempre più
tecnologico che viene fatto a me una
polaroid che i giochi ora non vengono
sempre però il fuoco per preparare il
suo cuore freddo è morto alla mia ex o
chloe senti fatti uccidere dal demonio e
basta mi dispiace ti prego aiutami non
mi devo dire quello che ho detto è gli
incoerenti come lo schifo in terra
proprio come la mia ex uguale o cota ma
te lo giuro su dio distacco le braccia
cosa mi sta succedendo in cucina la
bambola in fiamme chi si ricorda dalla
cucina la casa enorme
immagino che sia qui avvicinano esatto
reps hai lasciato il tacchino in forno
un po troppo
no gli togli il tacchino che poi un
casino questo successo la u
l'ho preso veramente anomica episodio
alla presa
l'ho presa sul serio non ci credo in ciò
occorrono dove puoi veramente difenderti
finalmente puoi usare l'ascia proprie
porte chiuse rompendo le maniglie
dai che figata
sì però magari tienila anche morale la
butti per terra dopo bastardo il dopo
miss anche se mi avvicino ok sono beni a
e per il forno ma posso tira fuori il
colpo dal forno si è cosa abbiamo qua
invoco demonio perfetto
chi è che suona io vorrei andare a casa
se possibile andare avanti di volte
parte sfondare
ma va a cagher t che suona basta il
presidio erotica azzardo ma parte che
era chiuso pianoforte come mm baby clos
e io sono questa tizia un po invecchiata
immagino però sono questa tizia bene io
sono la mamma di chloe avanti la vasca
da bagno regata va bene neanche troppo
soft direi ho visto di peggio
questo potrebbe essere un problema
ve lo dico io se ci fosse il riflesso
nello specchio mi caga ray in mano da un
momento all'altro nel vedere qualcosa 86
2862 che raga 862
da qualche parte devo mettere 862 non so
dove però sarà un lucchetto qualcosa
spacca spaccatutto spacca porca vacca
semi cadoni tra secondi tasha duro
tackle 8628 se 2 manca il pezzo fia
perché c'era il quadro davanti che pirla
pierre quadro solido 4 6 2
chiudi che evitiamo gli sprechi allora
48 62 perfetto
vedi ragazzi concludo più questo primo
episodio di nonno don con soft dirlo
malissimo perché non so dirlo mi sia
piaciuto perché sono se non ti piace che
periodicamente si chiede e ci diamo loro
personali dai ragazzi
[Musica]